bonsoir dans ce journal l'opération
menée à la cité des tarterets tôt ce
matin sous les objectifs de nombreuses
caméras 220 policiers se sont déployés
dans la cité ils ont arrêté 12 personnes
soupçonnées d'avoir participé à
l'agression la semaine dernière de deux
crs
les quatre otages français enlevés au
yémen il ya quinze jours ont été libérés
aujourd'hui ils sont arrivés à sanaa la
capitale dans la journée à l'écart de la
presse
il devrait rentrer en france d'ici 48
heures hier soir sur france 3 thierry
breton annonçait une généralisation très
prochaine dans les stations-service de
la distribution d'éthanol de carburant
obtenu à partir entre autres de la
betterave
l'enquète de ce 19 ans portera sur
l'expérience menée en suède les
carburants verts et alimente deux
voitures neuves sur 10
et puis nous irons au théâtre de la gare
où les humoristes d'eau et catella poète
de l'absurde produisent jusqu'à fin
décembre un spectacle hilarant
à l'heure du laitier 220 policiers sont
intervenus ce matin entre